[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
aujourd'hui hugues aufray qui vient de
fêter ses 91 ans qui sort un nouvel
album
autoportrait bonjour il offrait avec
juliette gréco
vous êtes les deux doyens de la chanson
française
est ce que vous avez en commun tous les
deux avec gilet gréco c'est que vous
n'avez jamais changé vous n'avez jamais
suivi les modes vous êtes resté vous
personnellement un chanteur de folk
curieux de tous les folklores mais un
chanteur français qui chantent en
français c'est le cas encore dans dans
cet album autoportrait oui écrit toutes
les paroles donc c'est en français et
comme je m occupe de dire on me demande
pourquoi des fois j'ai traduit certaines
chansons américaines et notamment bob
dylan
j'ai servi mozilla parce que je
comprends pas l'enlever
je n'ai pas eu la chance de faire des
boîtes étude de l'ordre ce qui veut dire
tout à fait normal en france on n'est
pas très doué pour ça et je ne comprends
pas l'anglais quand il est chanté je le
comprend un petit peu quand il est parlé
je parle pas très bien mais j'ai traduit
hôpital parce que j'adorais sa musique
comme des millions d'êtres humains
d'ailleurs et en particulier en france
et qui ne pouvaient et pc ce chanteur et
ses chansons sans comprendre un mot de
ce qu'il disait alors que j'ai trouvé
que c'était curieux comme situation et
je me suis dit ben je vais traduire les
chansons de celle de ce poète qui me
touche beaucoup pour que les gens
sachent de quoi il parle
voilà c'est exactement la raison pour
laquelle je je je continue encore dans
ce disque là de faire appel dès fois
aller à des manceaux qui sont désormais
des chansons du folklore originale des
états unis autoportrait cevam à une
synthèse de toutes les musiques
américaines il ya du funk il ya de la
country il ya du blues
il ya du rock cc c'est ça continue de
vous fasciner à ce point l'amérique
aujourd'hui hugues aufray alors à
avant d'aller plus loin je voudrais vous
faire remarquer que quand ce disque est
sorti avant qu'il s'en ma maison disque
m'a demandé une photo de moi récente et
il m'avait volé faire la photo par
confier ce travail à jean baptiste
mondino qui est un artiste magnifique
que j'aime bien et qui me vient il est
venu ici pour prendre des repères leur
plaira il n'y a pas de faire la photo à
cause du confinement
alors on était un peu en difficulté
lorsque mon de celui qui est s'occupe de
mes relations publiques
sébastien ogier sébastien da sidi
pendant ce son nom m'échappe et
sébastien racine sy a vu dans mon
atelier
un tableau que j'avais fait sur deux
morceaux de planches un jour comme ça il
ya au 15 ans et il ya eu 10 mais ça
serait intéressant de médecins pour eux
sur la prochaine de ton disque
il a proposé sa lyre salle qui s'est
emballé et on a donc choisi ces deux
planches ce qui explique qu'il ya au
milieu du visage un trait qui s'est
passé c'est l'endroit où des deux là ont
fait part voilà c'est les planches que
j'ai récupéré comme ça et j'ai fait cet
autre portrait quand on m'a demandé quel
est le titre de l'album je dis bien tout
naturellement on avait remarqué
autoportrait
on arrive donc ça c'était le bon ton
répondre à des questions que les jeunes
me pose un mot d'ailleurs où vous êtes
la gaufre est exactement
vous êtes chez vous mais je vous parle
je suis je suis à marly le roi qu'il
était le roi parce que c'est ici
qu'habitent et louis xiv
avant de faire construire versailles
celles que verse à il a construit rsa et
à la suite d'une soirée
donc il n'a pas apprécié le ch et son
premier ministre
fouquet qui avait organisé une grande
soirée prestigieuse dans son magnifique
château avec 3 un feu d'artifice
louis xiv et énervé par la splendeur de
l'habitation de son premier ministre
l'ami immédiatement en prison il l'a
d'ailleurs il a demandé à son fidèle
d'artagnan de s'occuper de le mettre en
prison et il a désigné un site bien
conçu et versailles
mais avant d'être à versailles il
habitait marly-le-roi marie leroy via le
mes est un joli village qui est pas le
dividende de 20 salles et jeune fille
dans la maison que un bâti grand
sculpteur métier c'est un piètre
architectes faut dire qu'il était très
pauvre à l'époque quand il s'est
installé là il a construit cette maison
c'est aristide maillol qui avait été
vous savez un mayol et catalans et il
habite à banyuls en été il fait très
très chaud et c'est un billet
impressionniste qui était beaucoup sur
le bord de scène lui ont dit en été
quand il fait très chaud tu devrais
venir dans la région parisienne
il fait plus frais à l'époque il faisait
plus frais c'est pareil et donc mayol il
est lucide en 1903 il a loué il a trouvé
une maison pierres qui étaient utilisées
sous toujours mais qui lui convenait pas
vraiment il s'est construit un atelier
et quand il a gagné un peu d'argent dans
les années 10 ne sommes peut-être 1920
je crois il a poursuit cette maison est
il quand il est mort en 44 la maison
étaient fermés et les respects permet
jusqu'à ce qu'elles se soient ouvertes
pour moi il ya deux ans voilà j'habite
donc dans la maison d'aristide maillol
été construit par bagnols et comme je
vous dis c'est un très grand sculpteur
mais la maison elle est spéciale mais je
suis fier d'eux et on
alors ma gueule parce que je me souviens
quand vous avez été fait commandeur des
arts et lettres par renaud donnedieu de
vabres à l'époque qui était prévu le
ministre de la culture
je crois que c'était déjà au musée
maillol avec dina vernis qui avait été
sa son égérie pendant très longtemps dit
oui j'avais demandé c'est dina vierny
qui m'a remis la médaille
dina vierny cette merveilleuse ces
femmes de gerry qui a sauvé mayol
mondial de l'oubli parce que après la
guerre le monde des arts était
extrêmement sévère avec l'artiste
figuratif il fallait être abstrait et
quand comme je dis abstrait c'est encore
un mot très généreux et dina vierny
était le dernier modèle de bayonne elle
laquelle bayonne en je crois en 1934 et
elle a été pendant dix ans son modèle et
elle va être aussi après sa mort celle
qui va pouvoir défendre l'oeuvre de
mayol est sauvée mayol des cars 2 du
louvre où il était évidemment destinée
comme tous les autres artistes qui me
qui lui faisait de l'art en direct
figuratif bourgeois pour l'époque vague
de deux comédiens de marxisme terrible
dans le dans la culture et tous ceux qui
n'étaient pas abstrait révolutionnaires
étaient classés et donc c'est elle qui a
trouvé l'oeuvre de marivaux et mais qui
a créé le musée maillol où m'avez vu
dans var mais cette médaille
et lorsque l'on m'a proposé cette
médaille aurait dit oui ce que tu veux
quand tu arrêtes et j'ai dit ok
parce que moi comme j'avais comme vue 18
ans après avoir passé mon baccalauréat g
je suis rentré l'été à malpassé n'ont
pas choqué le real madrid
je suis rentré en france à paris dans
l'espoir de faire les beaux-arts j'ai
pas pu faire et je dis ma vie en tant
que chanteur mais quand j'avais 10 12 13
14 ans je n'avais qu'un rêve c'était
d'être peintre sculpteur et j'étais prêt
à vivre comme c'est pour artiste de
génie qu'on était cézanne gauguin van
gogh
ça ne me faisait pas peur il n'avait pas
du tout l'intention d'être chanteur
c'est le hasard et la nécessité qui a
fait de moi un chanteur comme vous le
savez des années ayant passé les
retrouver dix navires lit j'avais 70 ans
et je lui dis je les ai vus à banyuls 1
j'étais allé voir sur le musée et quand
après un sortant des musées je les ai
rencontrés au restaurant et je me suis
approché belge lui parler et lui avouer
que je mon rêve c'était d'être sculpteur
et elle m'a dit cette phrase historique
pour moi une vous avez 70 ans
il n'est pas trop tard c'est impossible
elle m'a dit venez me voir un baril et
je vais vous raconter un peu l'histoire
elle a disparu elle avait dix ans de
plus loin seulement et à son enterrement
je suis venu à la demande de son fils
chanteurs et musiciens sur sa tombe et
quelque temps après j'ai découvert que
cette maison était fermée et grâce à son
fils olivier leur cas
j'ai pu lire m'installer ici on a
rouvert la maison on l'a reconstruit
parce qu'elle était en train de tomber
en ruine hugues aufray on va écouter
tout de suite ou plutôt on va regarder
tout de suite un extrait de
de votre clip d'anker voilà du folklore
que vous avez adapté en français on vous
écoute tout de suite
[Musique]
sur son twitter
ça passait là
[Musique]
john tucker
des brokers
le feu
porter
quand je
dégâts
faites passer
dans tout cela un peu
or monsieur renard
le caviar les robes qui gère les bons
cigares vie sans histoire rentre chez
toi
le
d'ailleurs pour faire
on va
[Musique]
hugues aufray c'est la vraie jim du
débarquement qu'on voit là a lancé jeep
a fait le débarquement en 44 elle m'a
été offert par un homme merveilleux
andré le coq était un des plus grands
carrossiers du monde mais restera les
cubaines voiture les hispano suiza les
bonnes clés et ils avaient mon âge
exactement on était très amis
on était du même mois de la même année
le froid même du même jour et il savait
que je rêvais d'avoir c'est un caprice
ça coûte cher c'est pareil abordable
mais enfin quand même c'est un caprice
et je n'ai jamais eu de type
et lorsqu'il est décédé il avait l'art
décidé de m'offrir ce type certainement
un des plus beaux cadeaux de que je vis
dans ma ville parce que c'est une
voiture extraordinaire mais qui
représente beaucoup de choses pour moi
et leurs grandes choses sur le plan
philosophique elle le concept de cette
voiture est génial et le fait que ça
soit un cadeau de l'amitié de cet homme
qui était merveilleux andré le corre qui
est bonne quand j'ai enregistré ce ce
clip de 25 heures j'étais contente
d'ailleurs dans la chanson je parle de
la banque sa jeep de baroudeur ce que je
n'ai pas été qu'un mois j'ai vécu
beaucoup d'hier
depuis mon enfance c'est à dire depuis
la guerre d'espagne que j'ai vécu de
très près parce que mon père avait
toutes ses affaires en espagne jusqu'à
la fin de la guerre d'algérie etc
j'ai traversé toute agréable sans jamais
sans jamais faire la guerre et ça
c'était un peu un complexe pour moi
parce que j'ai énormément d'admiration
pour les gens parce que j'ai coutume de
dire être pacifiste parce qu'à un moment
donné c'était mode chez les artistes
d'être pacifistes à il était engagé le
et pacifiste pacifistes en paix c'est
très facile en temps de guerre c'est
beaucoup plus complexe et je crois que
le monde est d'une grande complexité et
ça les jeunes ont tendance à boucle
alors que celle de jeep représente
beaucoup ceux d'entre eux est dans le
juste un petit mot pour vous dire que le
clip a été tourné sur la première maison
qui existent de loin la première maison
de mayotte maison en pierre qui est
maintenant abandonné leurs vins
bordelais qui n'est pas ouverte et qui
est couverte de lierre et c'est le décor
de 2 du clip
quand on dit 'tiens je disais il offrait
que cet album est une synthèse de toutes
les musiques américaines vous-même avait
toujours été fasciné par l'amérique à la
fois une voie est les voitures
américaines comme cette grippe mais
c'est les vestes à franges
on vous verra dans cette émission assez
soit avec des vestes à franges
typiquement tu es américaine est-ce que
la fascination est toujours aussi forte
on le dirait en écoutant cet album tout
et américains dans cet album
oui alors c'est bien parce que ça choque
pas mal de gens il me demande est ce que
pour vous le raid américain surtout avec
tout ce qui se passe actuellement est ce
qu'il s'est pas éteint effondré et je
réponds non
la preuve est qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
10 millions des millions et des millions
peut-être vena milliard d'êtres humains
qui rêvent de s'embarquer sur un bateau
mais pas un bateau pneumatique ont
traversé la méditerranée et venir
trouver du travail en europe
il rêverait de pouvoir traverser
l'atlantique et d'aller en amérique
malgré tout quand j'ai chanté beaucoup
d' en europe centrale à l'époque de
l'union soviétique
j'ai très souvent rencontré des jeunes
femmes très jolie qui me disaient j'ai
2000 l'équivalent de va dire de 1000
euros parce qu'à l'époque ce n'est pas
des euros enfin dollar nous sommes
importantes essayé de me trouver en
france un jeu un jeune homme y compris
le 6 est nécessaire un nouveau sexuelle
qui acceptera de faire un mariage blanc
de façon à ce que je puisse sortir de
nos pays la tchécoslovaquie la hongrie
la roumanie ou bien l'urss et maple leaf
il m'a demandé ça j'en ai rencontré des
cent des votes
pas des centaines mais beaucoup des
dizaines des dizaines évidemment je n'ai
rien pu faire penser pour filles qui se
sont peut-être débrouiller par là dessus
en revanche peut regretter aux états
unis où j'ai été souvent à new york dans
les quartiers pauvres de harlem pour
écouter assister aux offices religieux
qui était fabuleux je ne lis jamais
rencontré un un pauvre américain jeunes
une jeune fille qui me disait il
c'est vrai j'ai de l'argent j'ai
quelques dollars que je te donne
c'est le seul mois venir en europe alors
donc je continue à penser que le raid
américain
il a occupé tout le xxème siècle mais
c'est plus loin ça c'est de l'art
moderne
le monde moderne le 20e siècle
ces américains grâce à l'arrivée et qui
sait afro américains qui vont dans des
conditions épouvantables des migrants
esclaves à venir s'installer sur ce
continent en se mélangeant avec les
protestants et catholiques qui est une
musique qui le gospel qui va devenir le
jazz qui va devenir le blues qui va
devenir le rock la peinture africaine va
bouleverser la vision des peintres en
france notamment picasso qui doit
beaucoup aux masques africains
le jeu ne prend pas de l'adoma
littérature de minerai de tous ces
genres de tous et voilà le cinéma
évidemment le xxème siècle pour moi cet
américain alors aujourd'hui je suis le
premier à dire il ya des tas de choses
qui sont dramatiques aux états unis mais
malgré tout puisqu elles peuvent
terminer là dessus
quand j'ai rencontré quand j'ai
rencontré martin luther king en 66 et
que j'ai si tu chantais pour lui pour le
premier concert donné en faveur de la
lutte contre le racisme
j'ai chanté pour lui il était là j'étais
en vie
et par harry belafonte c'était le seul
français à chanter dans ce concert et je
viens une photo et par la suite quand il
est rentré aux états unis martin luther
king m'a envoyé une lettre pour me
remercier mr je pense qu'aujourd'hui si
martin luther king revenez me voir ici
parce que martin luther king était né
comme moi en 1929
donc il aurait mon âge eh bien il serait
le premier à reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des stars mondiales dans le cinéma
dans la danse dans la chanson à la
télévision partout des gens des noirs
des blacks des gens qui sont débuté
avant cas et nous avons vu un président
alors on n'a pas le droit on n'a pas le
droit de décourager les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui en leur disant c'est
encore ça va de plus en plus mal et
l'amérique d'aujourd'hui c'est pire que
l'amérique 10 à 60 ans on peut pas dire
ça c'est un mensonge historique mais
mais il faut évidemment lutte et lutter
et on n'aura jamais fini de lutter
contre le racisme
si longtemps on finira un jour mais pour
l'instant il ya encore beaucoup de
travail
hugues aufray vous avez vous l'avez dit
vous avez passé votre bac à madrid vous
êtes arrivé à paris vous avez commencé à
chanter un peu par accident vous l'avez
souvent raconté les la preuve parmi les
premières chansons que vous enregistrez
il ya y'avait fanny une chance en 1958
que vont reprendre tous les les appeler
qui partent pour la guerre d'algérie
arrivent ensuite les yéyés et arrive
johnny hallyday qui sera votre votre
grand copain à ceux-là ils sont beaucoup
plus jeunes que vous ils ont 15 ans -
comme ou à peu près ils sont tous
imbibés de rock'n'roll et comment
comment vous vous situez par rapport à
vous serez sur la même photo la fameuse
photo de jean marie périer en 1966 ce
qu'on appelle en france la photo du
siècle où il ya 46 vedette
vous êtes les deux plus âgés ils agacent
bourg et vous et puis à tous les autres
qui sont jeunes qui ont grandi avec le
rock n roll comment voulez regardiez
vous c'était compliqué c'est compliqué
comme j'ai dit le formule qui a été
reprise par un journaliste et deux après
j'étais un peu fâché d'avoir dit ça mais
je vais vous le dire j'étais le plus
vieux des jeunes parce que tous ces gens
là qui sera en photo et est considérée
comme la nouvelle chanson française
la nouvelle génération les jeunes et
bien il y avait deux qui dit plusieurs
le clézio de tous c'était quand même
il y avait il y avait une loup-garou qui
avait un homme plus loin je crois elle
aussi les pages sur la photo il n'est
pas sur la photo sur la photo des îles
sont pas sur la photo
ces gaz bord et vous les trois
agresseurs usagers gaz bourg et vous
voilà c'est bien ce bourg et moi qui
avais cotisations rentrer dans cette
espèce de classes nouvelles qui étaient
entre guillemets les yéyés mais je
pourrais dire que un jour aussi 12
journalistes bien sûr je réponds aux
questions qu'on me pose
j'ai trouvé une formule que ce soit
intéressante a dit comment vous situez
par rapport à gainsbourg
j'écrivais un côté servait moi j'aime
beaucoup les femmes lire j'aime beaucoup
inspiré de la façon d'écrire des
chansons comme me l'a font-elles
écrivait ses fables d'après eux et
d'octobre d'ailleurs lui aussi faisait
deux adaptations et il ya une femme que
j'aime bien c'est le rat des villes et
le rat des champs alors on pourrait dire
que gainsbourg c'est le rat des villes
et marcher sur le rat des champs
je crois que l'image est bonne parce que
lui c'est un nocturne
il sortait le soir à partir de 6 heures
du soir ils allaient me sortait il
rentrait à 6h du matin moi c'est
exactement le contraire je me lève à 6h
du matin je ne me couche pas à six
heures du soir donc dans ma dent d'un
joker houleux
la chanson mon art en tant que valeur
jeudi d'un joker évidemment l'auteur
c'est une auto caricature mais je dis
des choses rien sûrement jeudi dans son
coeur il se lève tôt et ils se couchent
tard je me lève à 6h30
je me couche jamais lui met donc voilà
gainsbourg et noir ont été les deux rats
dans ce lot de jeunes et c'était pas
facile
c'était pas facile effectivement ils
avaient entre 10 et 15 ans de moins que
moi et moi à l'époque on faisait tout le
monde faisait ce que vous faites encore
à savoir adapter les tubes anglo-saxons
en français expliquer pourquoi on
comprenez pas l'anglais
c'est la meilleure manière de comprendre
les chansons et c'est quelque chose qui
ne se fait plus on le faisait pas que
pour les chansons anglaises je me suis
un allah mouskouri qui avait fait la
version française de the girl from
ipanema la chanson brésilienne de de
chevy mais est mauvaise on le faisait
pour toutes les chansons vous te prouver
qu'on a perdu quelque chose en arrêtant
de faire ça mais je vais vous dire
franchement il ya un serpent technics
claude il y avait un problème la musique
française traditionnelle est construite
sur la norme française évidemment
l'accent tonique finale est toujours
fort on dit par exemple comme j'avais
beaucoup marché
j'étais très très fatiguée on appuie et
et dans la musique anglo saxonne qui est
elle-même naturellement autrement qu'à
danser on a tendance à dire pour dire
cette phrase on aurait dit l'accent
tonique c'est sur l'avant dernière note
cela dit comme j'avais beaucoup marché
la cabane au fond du jardin de cavale
et quand cette révolution c'est moi qui
les fais d'ailleurs parce que en france
que je ne vous dis comme je vais
beaucoup marché est très très fatiguée
j'aperçois une ferme
je veux dire je vais m'arrêter c'est une
chanson de dylan bien lorsque j'ai
traduit cette chanson avec la
collaboration de pierre delanoë qui lui
il n'avait pas beaucoup dylan le pays de
même pas du tout il connaissait pas
cette musique et il m'a dit mais u
on ne peut pas dire comme j'avais
beaucoup marcher ça ne se dit pas c'est
pas un accent et beaucoup de gens ont
cru que quand cabrel dit la cabane au
fond du jardin
ces deux élections 2010 c'est pas vrai
c'est pas du tout l'accent du midi
c'est une américanisation du français
est aujourd'hui te me fait ça dans la
chanson française et cette révolution
est très importante parce que ça change
complètement le concept musical
alors effectivement pourquoi on faisait
beaucoup d'adaptation d'après des
chansons américaines
eh bien c'était pour retrouver cette
réplique à qui ils constituent ce qu'on
appelle le swing le balancement est ce
que je peux vous dire une chose que
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas le verbe
to work
le to what en anglais ça veut dire
baisser par exemple rockincher rock in
chair c'est là la chaise qui se balance
et c'est ce monde utilisent pour baisser
les enfants voient l'origine les noirs
berset les enfants ils ont écrit mes
ballades qui balançaient les enfants et
c'est les blancs français qui vont
adapter ses chansons à leur façon et qui
vont y apporter cette note de violence
et de haine bellion
comme personnellement je n'apprécie pas
toujours et faire du rock'n'roll
une musique agressive comme le rap
alors donc les adaptations sur les
chansons américaines ont permis à toute
une génération de jeunes de pouvoir
s'exprimer avec le balancement
nécessaire pour que les gens puissent
danser et se sentir dans le coup alors
ce n'était plus la valse à trois temps
c'était comme j'étais jeune on envoyait
des accords de listes partout dans les
rues
on voyait pas les guitaristes c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi j'ai commencé à
trouver du travail très rapidement c'est
à la mairie que guitar ouvriers
personnes un des rites à l'accordéon a
disparu le budget est devenu carrément
un petit folkore et c'est la guitare et
la musique africaine
la batterie et la basse ont fait une
pause et hugues aufray on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
on continue de revenir sur la longue
carrière du coffret qui sort un nouvel
album
autoportrait
hugues aufray vous parliez de bob dylan
et
je me suis toujours demandé comment vous
vous rencontrez je crois que c'est très
tôt en 1961 à greenwich village pour
rencontrer bob dylan à une époque
faisait la première partie de peter paul
and mary
ensuite quand il viendra à paris en 64
pour son concert vous l'emmenez dans
paris c'est vous qui levait la d63
pardon et puis va vous donner
l'autorisation d'adapter ses chansons et
vous allez beaucoup contribué au fait
qu'il va être connus en france grâce à
vos adaptation vous chanterez avec lui
sur scène au parc de sceaux dans les
années 80 vous avez chanté ensemble the
times they are a changing mais je le
suis aux demandes et étendez votre
mauvais anglais vous le dites vous même
vous ne parlait pas l'anglais
comment vous parliez tous les deux parce
que ils ne parlent pas le français en a
que défense j'avais au départ
alors c'est en 61 j'ai passé huit jours
à new york où j'étais invité par maurice
chevalier qui devait chanter leurs
soirées de conte dirais-je de vérité
pour un hôpital à l'hôpital d'enfants dé
et il avait voulu que avoir ces gouttes
et un jeunes chanteurs de la nouvelle
génération et après une casting lequel
cette chaude elle est pratiquée ville la
place donc j'ai été invité vision c'est
là que la première fois que je vois
bob dylan dans un petit kamar el sens
une connaître sans eau sans pouvoir lui
parler je suis rentré en france en me
disant mais mon dieu ce que j'ai vu là
est ce que j'ai entendu c'est incroyable
je reviendrai dans ce pays parce que je
veux d'ailleurs je voulais émigrés ça je
suis un émigrant qui a échoué et donc je
suis revenue comme aides en 62 parce que
j'avais réussi à trouver un cabaret où
qui voulait m'engager et ce cabaret
s'appelle blue angels et il y avait une
comédienne dont j'ai oublié le nom titi
faisait la vedette et il y avait des
jeunes parce que c'était le trempe là de
la nouvelle chanson
à new york le l'ange bleu new york globe
angels il y avait effectivement un trio
peter paul and mail et c'est eux qui
fréquentait le village et avec eux de
sympathiser et il m'a emmené au village
et là j'ai pu retrouver et rencontré bob
dylan et donc j'avais à ce moment là un
copain qui parlait l'anglais et le
français qui traduit qui traduisait tout
ce que je disais on vient d'apercevoir
la une photo de moi avec un petit renard
oui j'ai pour une parenthèse quelques
photos est historique parce que au
moment où le photographe va faire la
photo à dallas un homme vise le
président kennedy et à quelques secondes
près en même temps que le photographe et
la photo le tireur tir et tu assassines
qu'elle ait dit on a vraiment calculé le
jour l'heure et la seconde près c'est à
une seconde près à vingt dix secondes
près le moment où il a été tué sacré
coïncide dans la section est donc ça
c'est pour vous donner la date est donc
je e
il va revenir en 63 et je vais
l'accueillir au bourget parce que horny
n'existe pas je les ai accueillis au
bourget avec eux à une gourde en peau de
chèvre ou une gourde basque plein devant
et on savait de ces bourdes qu'on doit
comme salariale et j'avais accueilli
avec ça accompagné par le monde
mon cousin mais son fun berg américain
évidemment qui parlait très bien
français puisqu'il était marié avec ma
cuisine cook it et c'est grâce à mes
jeunes que je vais pouvoir parler avec
bob c'est lui qui va me donner les
traductions des premières chansons que
je vais pouvoir ensuite réalisé à venir
en français avec l'aide considérable
jean pierre de saint marc qui est un
musicien exceptionally pianiste parce
que le phrasé de d'image et des
paiements complexe et brian n'était pas
toujours symétrique
on pourrait pas dire qu'il y avait une
symétrie quoi qu'on retrouve chaque fois
comme dans la chanson française couplet
refrain couplet refrain
c'était compliqué jean pierre savare
nous a expliqué comment où étaient les
accents toniques importants et avec
pierre delanoë nous avons un lui le
premier disque qui s'appelait aufray
chante dylan alors ce disque va marquer
la jeunesse en particulier des gens
comme renault comme comme jean jacques
goldman vont découvrir bob dylan par ces
nations très vite il mais comme ils sont
musiciens par exemple sur jacques il va
évidemment écouter zidane qu'il va
trouver que c'est beaucoup mieux chanté
par lui que par mois francis cabrel
pareil ça mais c'est tout à fait normal
j'ai jamais un prétendu bs je voudrais
simplement vous dire que moi mon idée
quand même c'est une idée philosophique
de ma vie c'est le partage
j'aime pas jouir tout seul d'avoir un
grand plaisir si je vais voir un beau
film j'irai nous revoir tout seul
j'irai le revoir avec intervalle un bon
camarade pour avoir le plaisir de le
revoir le film avec lui et bien de la
même façon il avait eu plaisir à chanter
bob dylan en français parce que vous
riez le plaisir immense que je faisais à
tous ces jeunes qui se disait mais bon
sang on sait maintenant de quoi
de quoi parle cette chanson notamment en
europe centrale ou en tchécoslovaquie
il ne parlait pas l'anglais et ils ont
fait de moi me star parce que je chante
dylan en français yahia aux lettres de
vaud adaptation vous avez fait vos parmi
vos plus grands succès me semble utile
lors que ce soit santiano hasta luego
les crayons de couleurs adieu monsieur
le professeur ce sont des chansons qui
ont passionné les cours de récréation
les enfants ou adoré ces chansons là ils
les ont chanté entre eux les ont chanté
à l'école leurs professeurs les heurts
ont fait chanter j'ai l'impression vous
avez toujours une des raisons de votre
longévité c'est cela c'est que les
enfants reprennent vos chansons qu'est
ce qui fait que je suis sûr que dans
l'album que vous venez de sortir d'un
autoportrait vous reprenez hasta luego
vous reprenez stewball aussi je suis sûr
que vous y pensez on va entendre tout de
suite d'ailleurs vous parliez de jean
jacques goldman environ deux mois vous
entendre avec michael jones en train de
réenregistrer stewball pour cette
version et après vous me direz qu est ce
qui plaît aux enfants
est ce que vous vous posez la question à
chaque fois on vous écoute ball est une
chanson magnifique que tout le monde
connaît et pour la réenregistrer j'ai
pensé à michael jones
je sais
je m'appelle
que tu
à nier
[Musique]
j'appris
riguet
elle est
hugues aufray est ce que les enfants
restent un public important pour vous et
comment s'adresse-t-on à eux
alors moi je crois que il faut
revêtissent ou dans le bon sens j'ai
jamais écrit de chansons pour enfants
j'ai jamais me suis jamais bien réel
talent tiens je vais faire une chanson
pour enfants j'ai fait une chanson que
j'avais deux dans le coeur que la
mélodie m'avait inspiré du môle j'avais
entendu chanter ça n'a rien rien à voir
avec l'histoire que je raconte des
histoires c'est moi qui ai inventé et
j'écris j'ai écrit cette chanson qui se
trouve que les adultes ont aimé et alors
évidemment les écouteurs ses chansons
chez eux s'en tient de ce tube all et
c'est le petit âne gris et ils se sont
rendus compte que les enfants aiment est
par exemple beaucoup santiano qui est
fait que la chanson est rentrée à
l'école par les enfants et évidemment
c'est en forme de grandir grandir quand
dirais quand ils ont 40 ans 50 ans qui
se marient et ben ils chantent encore et
c'est de ça rentre dans les générations
et ça passe de l'enfance à la majorité
aux adultes tout naturellement iem ps
c'est pas une politique que j'ai menée
pendant des années pas du tout dans ce
nouveau disque je peux vous garantir
déjà qu'il ya des chansons qui vont être
reprises par les enfants parce que parce
que ce sont souvent les chansons qui
sont chantés par les enfants aux
etats-unis parce qu'elles ont un pouvoir
de simplicité d'interprétation elles
sont elles ne sont pas elles racontent
des histoires que sont pas des chansons
qui font appel à des évolutions comme on
dirait d'amour aux adultes se sont par
exemple l'amour d'un enfant pour un
cheval et ça c'est quelque chose de
simple un enfant pour un chat ou un
chien
les enfants ont du coeur et quand on
chante ses chansons à ça les touche
on n'a pas besoin de faire d'effort pour
les pour les faire chanter et dans ce
disque là je vous garantis dans celui là
est donc un prochain que j'ai déjà
enregistré et qui sortira plus tard à
noël les chansons vent est rentré dans
d'exactement parce qu'elles sont en
dehors du temps ça c'est à dire quelque
chose que je peux dire
elles sont c'est pas les chansons de qui
sont faits en fonction d'une mode et je
compte les enfants sont heureux de voir
de voir ses chances d'entendre ses
chansons comme on voit le lever du
soleil la lune
l'attrait de lune dans le ciel ou bien
les fleurs qui apparaissent dans un
jardin c'est naturel voilà c'est ça que
je crois qu'il qui plaît aux enfants et
aux adultes
il ya aussi la mélodie c'était des ce
sont des mélodies que l'on retient
facilement que l'on peut siffler que
l'on peut donc chanter j'ai l'impression
qu'on a on a perdu un peu le goût des
mélodies
aujourd'hui alors que vous avez démarré
une époque où ils s'étaient rennes la
mélodie et eren à l'époque ben oui bien
sûr mais si je vous chante par exemple
l'argent que tu es heureux
dormez vous dormez vous matez dean dont
dépendent donc c'est pas d'évolution son
tour enfants ça à l'origine c'est tout
je connais pas l'historique du soir je
mets le deuxième couplet va être la même
chose on va recommencer
c'est même ce qu'on appelle un canon
alors vous avez le bon roi dagobert de
mont-saint-éloi lui valent que le thème
c'est vrai visiblement je vais la
remettre à l'or noir et dambach abdallah
ça continue comme ça raconte l'histoire
ce bon roi dagobert
ou bien en passant par la lorraine à
metz entre temps reprend la même phrase
oui ces chansons sont simples et elles
sont faites par des gens qui sont
simples on pourrait dire même des gens
de peu c'est à dire presque toujours des
gens du peuple qui faisait ça pour
animer les fêtes de village pour animer
les soirées autour du feu que tout le
monde pouvait reprendre en choeur qui
racontaient des petites histoires des
fois dramatique mais qu'on chantait sans
pleurer contrairement au chant réaliste
de malik que chantelle fréhel que
chanter piaf damian quand bien ce genre
d'une chanson dramatique
dès le départ on voit qu'elle est
dramatique et on voit pas comment on
pourrait reprendre ou bien même ce ce
délit jacques brel quand il chante ne me
quitte pas on l'imaginé vous eu des
enfants qui chantent mon départ vous
justement je faisais allusion tout à
l'heure à la chanson que qui vous a fait
connaître la preuve une des premières
vous avez enregistré
fanny que vous chantez en 58 tous les
tous les appels en algérie vont
reprendre cette chanson vous en
retrouverez aussi bien vous voyez la
chanter le très bien si j'avais si
j'étais au piano là je vous le rêve
jouer mais fanny jeu il faut être maître
c'est une chanson que j'aimais pas
composé i les parodies la 80ème à ce
report car je voulais démarrer
je voulais démarrer en 59 et je ne je ne
compose pas de chansons j'arrivais de
dix années où j'avais gagné ma vie en
chantant dans des cabarets dans les
restaurants faisant de l'animation pas
dû tourner au chant de l'animation
musicale et j'aime pas du tout
l'intention d'être et notre chanteur
professionnel
donc je ne compose est pas méchant sont
ces barques et qui m'a dit tu sais à vue
il va falloir que tu composes c'est
cette chanson mais fanny j'ai entendu
cette chanson elle m'a touché le coeur
et
je les enregistrer et de la même façon
que elle m'avait touchée elle a touché
un garçon de 20 ans qui partait pour
faire une guerre de plus et tout à fait
enfin remise en question par
politiquement et cette chanson donc à
accompagner ces jeunes et c'est par la
suite que je vais me décider
peu à peu en partant de folklore sud
américain que ce que laissait bien le
venezuela la bolivie pérou le mexique le
brésil
en repartant de ces photos là je vais
commencer à mettre des textes en
français puis après je vais arriver
passer la frontière du texas est arrivé
aux etats-unis
mais cette je suis devenu dur vedette
par hasard et par nécessité je voulais
dit dès le début de cette émission et il
faut pas le nier ça c'est un
apprentissage sur la scène justement je
serai quand on revienne à l'un blog mec
qui sort maintenant à autoportrait il ya
une très belle chanson dedans qui
s'intitule ya un homme qui rôde et qui
prend des noms
vous avez enregistré dans les coulisses
d'ailleurs un peu la jeunesse de cette
chanson on va on va le regarder vous
écoute et puis on en parle après parce
que c'est vraiment une très très belle
chanson celle ci
[Musique]
pour raconter cette histoire terrible
on a utilisé
un micro qui est fait avec une boîte à
sucre dans les restaurants pauvres on
est sur les tables aux états unis
sucre en poudre et les noirs fabriquer
des micros avec ses boîtes à sucre
évidemment le son est très particulier
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
je suis sûr que c'est des gens qui
viennent repérer nez noir c'est donc le
cul score j'ai évidemment découvert des
choses atroces fils
jouer à l'école 17 ans a été lynché
torturé puis brûlée vive devant 10000
personnes
j'étais sans cesse dans l'abbaye royale
à manicamp
[Musique]
e
ce n'est pas comment dirais-je pour des
raisons politiques que je m'intéresse
comme ça ce n'est pas des raisons
sociales debout ce sont des raisons
sociétal mais surtout humanitaire
[Musique]
ces fantômes kilos d'or pur et lilou
aujourd'hui quand on voit ce qui se
passe aux etats unis
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de travail encore dans ce
domaine
[Musique]
tél
il parle lui ce campagne à desbin
couleurs douces chansons
[Musique]
comme à la cool cette chanson au départ
il ya cette phrase que vous entendez ya
une mélodie aussi elles existent la
mélodie ou voulait composer je je je
trouve cette phrase je l'entends je ne
sais plus ce que je vais trouver mais
moi je crois je crois beaucoup au destin
on est guidé par quelque chose qui veut
qu'on appelle d'inspiration je ne sais
pas par hasard je trouve vers les mêmes
gorille brown t green days
il ya un l'homme qui qui tourne autour
et qui prend des dans ce disque et ça
veut dire ça il ya des bonnes musiques
je n'entends pas de musique je trouve
cette phrase alors je continue de
chercher puis je vois des photos ça
m'intéresse des photos noir et blanc qui
convoie des gens qui travaillent sur les
chemins de fer et des pauvres gens dans
des quartiers les noirs évidemment et
qui tend vers coup je me dis mais c'est
une chanson celle que ce corps qui est
derrière cette chanson est donc vos
mails complètement inventé tout le texte
que je chante dans cette chanson
l'histoire de ce garçon qui va être
opéré par le cusm qui va être jugé sans
être jugé et condamné à être pendu et
brûlé vif pour avoir violé une femme
blanche probablement mais il faut savoir
ce que des conditions de vie ces gens là
étaient tellement terrible
il est possible qu'ils avaient vu des
plus grands tels faits sam ce crime est
pas bien mais ce qu'ils le bolt c'était
pouvant tarder la façon dont il est mort
épouvantable devant 10000 personnes et
donc moi j'ai pris cette chanson en en
étudiant un petit peu après j'ai plongé
dans l'histoire depuis ce plan pour
savoir et les mots que j'ai mis ces
hommes aux visages pâles avec qui se
calcule en blanc appuyé le
robe couleur de sang du chef du clan
tout ça c'est des véhicules où ça sur le
plan historique et c'est vrai que on a
en fait cet enregistrement avec cette
boîte à sucre
parce que voilà c'est qu'il y avait
quelque chose en plus car c'est ces gens
étaient pauvres et ils jouaient sur les
guitares qui fabriquaient eux-mêmes avec
des fils de fer c'était incroyable
aujourd'hui le revenant c'est plus comme
ça mais quand même vos vidéos le hasard
a voulu qu au moment où disque sort il y
avait une seule rame aux états unis man
donc il ya comme je vais dit le tannat
ya encore beaucoup de travail pour pour
arriver à terminer avec ce racisme
meurtrier et quatre ans
il vaut frais l'histoire de la boîte à
sucre qui servait de micro ça m'a
rappelé que vous avez eu un des premiers
groupes de skiffle dans les années 60 ce
qu'ils font c'était justement qui ça
consistait à faire de la musique avec
des objets domestiques
il y avait la fameuse planche à laver
qu'on voit dans les albums de lucky luke
qui servait à faire la batterie
qu'est-ce que vous avez donnés en aux
smiths falls
ouais alors le mot skiffle je ne sais
pas si ça ne vient pas du tout aux deux
des rameurs le mot je les trouvais part
en angleterre
l'oni d'un élève qui était en hurlant
des droits qu'il tirerait son skiff
leveaux et comme barclay me demandait il
te faut un nom pour son orchestre
quelques tu as trouvé j'ai dit monsieur
prendre ce qu'ils veulent parce que à
mon avis c'est un bon qui serait bien
mais je crois que ça doit venir des
équipes de gens qui rame qui fait un
bond du skiff iphone bon pour venir vous
parvenir à mozac aux instruments la
porte je l'avais tout ça ça vient de la
pauvreté de ces gens comme vous les 10
les jambes mais peu ces gens pauvres
c'est loire de la louisiane qui n'avait
et qui faisait musique extraordinaire
avec très peu de moyens mais beaucoup de
talent le rythme était fait avec la
blanche à laver l'apport à la veille de
la planche à laver et qui peut un peu
ils ont commencé à récupérer des
instruments depuis saxophone car ils
vont devenir les j ai alors on va avoir
des gens comme françois leur qui joue du
piano art tatum et cuir va avoir par
exemple quelqu'un que j'adore qui n'a
simone et à simone tient du génie et qui
aurait pu faire une carrière de pianiste
classique extraordinaire qu'elle était
hyper louer quand elle s'est présentée à
eux ne fait pas dans quelle ville
elle était elle s'est présentée au
conservatoire pour faire ses études de
musique on le dit donc parce qu'elle
était noir
c'est quand même terrible ça ne le
pensait et quand vous voyez maintenant
l'enregistrement de nina simone qui
chante dirigeants de la direction
elle peut chanter n'importe quoi sans
doute il a déjà baissé ses
extraordinaires de puissance de talent
donc ces gens de peu parce qu'elle était
très pauvre
elle va être je crois qu'elle a touché
50 $ pour faire sans son tube je sais
plus loin s'appelle au piano qui sait
pas ce qu'elle même avait vendu les
droits de tous les albums il y avait my
baby just a band we may b b2 elle avait
vendu tous les droits de l'album est ce
qui fait qu elle a perdu les droits ce
qui devrait rapporter au moins un
million de dollars sur son
interprétation de la chanson de mike
bibby merci c'est ça l'histoire et vous
même qui avez est ce que vous êtes
content de votre carrière
aujourd'hui puisque vous l'avez dit
c'est un accident est ce que maintenant
quand vous regardez
rétrospectivement vous êtes fiers de
vous
c'est à dire que je n'avais pas prévu de
faire ça je vous ai parlé un tout petit
peu je ne sais pas si vous parler de mon
frère mais j'avais à faire
un homme plus que moi et qui m'a élevé
parce qu'en l'absence de mon père qui
était divorcé la guerre n'avait tenu
loin et par la suite
enfin bref c'est mon frère francesco qui
me m'apprendre à devenir un homme
j'ai été handicapé par le fait que
j'étais hyper gauche est utilisé à
l'envers de droite à gauche
je n'arrivais pas à apprendre l'alphabet
j'arrivais pas à prendre les notes
d'ailleurs j'ai jamais appris le solfège
j'étais énervé sic c'est à dire que le
petit garçon voyez ces deux frères
partir au collège
moi mon rêve c'était de partir avec eux
il était pensionnaire
je ne pouvais pas cautionner parce que
le petit garçon qui avait 7 8 ans
faisait pipi au lit
voilà et c'est eux ça n'a l'air de rien
mais c'est dramatique et grâce à ça
grâce à mon frère francesco je vais
pouvoir m'en sortir
puis avait une voix naturelle qui a fait
de lui un chanteur d'opéra international
une des plus grandes voix du 20ème
siècle et il est parti aux états unis
les partis au canada sur vue conseil il
allait rejoindre les états unis pour
démarrer une carrière alors que il est à
ce moment là un grand chagrin d'amour
victime d'un 1.6 d'ailleurs puisque il
voulait épouser une petite jeune fille
chinoise et les parents se sont opposés
et mon frère qui était un garçon très
particulier qui avait tendance à vivre
dans le drame peu comme sont les gens
dans l'opéra a choisi de quitter ce
monde s'est suicidé est évidemment
j'avais 24 ans
jean j'avais 26 ans et d'enlever 27 et
si j'ai fait cette carrière
c'est de toute évidence un transfert
n'apporte guère de 6,4 vous dirais que
c'est le transfert je ne n'avais pas pu
faire une sculpture j'avais pu faire ma
peinture je gagnais mes idées ma vie
comme musicien et tout d'un coup tout
d'un coup c'est après 50,5 après des
mois 55
et pour terminer je me terminer cette
anecdote dramatique en vous disant que
sa mort a été tellement tragique que
maman n'a rien voulu savoir comment ça
s'était passé rien savoir et on n'a
jamais su où il était enterré pensé
qu'il était mort au canada probablement
à montréal et ce n'est qu'il ya un an
laurent tournée que j'ai un jeune qui
conduisait le bus qui m'a dit je vais
retrouver la tombe de votre frère il a
cherché à chercher avec quelques détails
que je lui ai dit ce qui était pas bon
d'ailleurs il a réussi à trouver le
bâton et mon frère est simple et
francesco à cause de la direction que
maman avec ses enfants soient aussi il
est enterré dans un cimetière qui
s'appelle le repos de saint françois
d'assise
merci c'était pour vous dire que je sais
pas pourquoi je vous ai raconté cette
histoire parce que c'est vous dire oui
on m'avait demandé si je suis content de
ma carrière
belle ma réponse est que j'ai fait tout
ce que j'ai pu pour être à la hauteur de
ce que mon frère croyait en moi parce
que sans que je puisse comprendre
pourquoi quand j'avais 18 ans
surveillant jeu des pianos alors je ne
savais pas jouer le piano que ne
savaient pas lire les notes ni m'a dit
une un jour tu seras concertiste
c'est faire des montages dit pourquoi tu
le dis ça ce sera concertiste et lorsque
j'ai eu mon dernier le concert de 2019
c'était à pleyel lorsque je suis entré
sur scène à pleyel j'ai pensé à mon
frère veut dire dont se réaliser merci
nos frais d'avoir passé toute cette
émission avec nous je rappelle que
autoportrait votre nouvel album vient de
sortir
et bien merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]